[Musik]
genau so dass man halt einfach nur weiß
wenn ich nach der schule herum
da der im spital ist leben mit viel
tempo
[Musik]
da so auch die drei söhne der familie 4
der älteste und der jüngste haben beide
das down syndrom durch die zeche dafür
logisch auch ein kosmisches ganz
wichtige situation noch mitbestimmen was
sagen macht oder was land nicht gemacht
und seine zwei mal lädt zu seiner bürger
und zähle so sehr gern lange vor der
blüte ist was in den bug behoben sein
es muss dafür fördert die haltungen zu
sagen wir machen ich bringe und dem
gesetz bis ich halte zum beispiel den
klar die firma leikermoser aber mich
einfach irgendwas machen dass es für
alles probieren
[Musik]
du musst mit buch soße strecke
rasch ins bett
[Musik]
sie nahmen sich so
jaja mache hier heißen
[Musik]
nach der anfänglichen trauer ist im haus
der vers der turbulente alltag
eingekehrt
joel ist maßgeblich daran beteiligt dass
die beiden beeinträchtigten brüder an
allen facetten des familienlebens
teilhaben können
alaska mit dem show zusammen
wer aber dann lief er seit ich
sicherlich strandgut von rassismus mit
sache nochmal machen und so wird auch
ständig spieler die glauben so jetzt
mach das mal klar ja
ja super tag war sehr gut gemacht sagt
dass er diesen bedingunge zu spielen ist
[Musik]
die zwölfjährige sara mag sich heute
nicht mit ihren freundinnen treffen
[Musik]
das projekt findet man oft wild und
sauberes probiert ihre mutter silvia
geht es heute nicht gut
die 50 jährige leidet an rheumatoider
arthritis
auch polyarthritis genannt kommt ein
schub kann die krankheit silvia kette
riss muskeln nehmen dann besteht die
akute gefahr eines herzstillstandes
sarah packt an wo immer ihre hilfe
gebraucht wird
konflikte haben tochter und mutter
deswegen schon längst keine mehr und wir
verfügt hätte hätte ich das mal jemand
vorüber und wenn ein schub kommt geht
ohne saras unterstützung gar nichts mehr
also dass das macht sogar medikament
bringt und ich auch nur beschrieben und
dem sofa und tanzen
wieder muss meine karriere studierende
nicht so gut
[Musik]
wie denner situationen entwickler diese
oberste stelle wasserstelle studiere ich
weiß es nicht und ich mit einem ganz
ohne wissen der stadt eine fettschicht
den tag mit einer dicken schicht nutella
bestreichen
ja das sind wirklich dass das heißt sein
buch staubte schnittgut hätte ich so
dass ich mache ja
sarah ist das was die forschung als
young care als junge pfleger bezeichnet
janka es kümmern sich neben schule oder
lehre um kranke oder beeinträchtigte
eltern geschwister oder großeltern
neueste zahlen belegen in der schweiz
sind acht prozent aller kinder zwischen
zehn und 15 jahren jankers
agnes leu ist leiterin des
forschungsprogramms jankers die schweiz
steht im gegensatz zu großbritannien
noch am anfang der forschung
das spektrum ist enorm breit was es wenn
man aber mit schwierig macht das zu
fassen das ist sache sie wie das ganze
busse organisieren rechner erledigen
teilige machen
sehr oft sind es aber auch begleitung
auf tieren steht es keinen sozialen
zieht das kann aber irgend ein anderes
stellt sie wisse dass großbritannien das
motiv ausstieg hat mich hin wo um die
folge sind also die übernahme natürlich
emotionale support also drei begleiter
eines mitarbeiters wieder gern
und je älter sie werden mit viel mehr so
endlich dazu und solange sich nur im
sinne entwickelt dieses jahres völlig in
ordnung aber es war ja wahnsinnig vor
dem vgh und da denken muss man es
geschafft entscheide was du mir noch
kindgerecht die stufe und was nicht
[Musik]
du musst mal was ich vielleicht besser
für die nochmals nach kabinen daten holz
kanarien und er muss hat bei mir nicht
ein paar den datenschutz an
er gibt nur zweitklassig das sind sie
sehr sodass diese plötzlich befindet und
dass der wahrscheinlich einzige aspekt
dass dann dank ständig anstößig da gibt
es also wenn sie es macht einfach durch
kultur sowie abgelenkt von stored das
war nicht so bomba invasion für uns
werden wir als verein sv verliert
springt wurde wird das für sie wenn sich
sondern die 16 oder so gemacht
maschine verschiebe
[Musik]
das ist
der xi jinping war muss so seine ganz
eigene nicht
[Musik]
sarah hat die forscher an ihrem leben
als jan keller teilhaben lassen
da es zwischen tiroler wo ich so
schleicher dort ein ganz lieber und das
jetzt noch einige jahre macht ich finde
aussah wie sehr kann kommunizieren wenn
wenn sie ihren gurt gott oder wenn sie
seien ja das macht jetzt eigentlich nett
aber sie ist pädagogische als das jetzt
gottfried evers ihres hobby das heißt
sie haben sehr reflektiert ist und ich
weiß aber gar nicht ob sie so der
typische young care gibt will jeder
mensch für sich so individuell ist und
so ihre ganz eigene situation und
belastungsfähigkeit für jeden menschen
so unterschiedlich
der 17 jährige anna besucht eine
sonderschule sein 15-jähriger bruder
joel die dritte klasse der
sekundarschule in der freizeit ist er
leidenschaftlicher hobby filmer
aber nach so strache
dieser sieg war nach knapp ist doof die
sich speziell um so versuche ich das im
film übersetzt bringen dass max
aber die ist die sie nicht noch mal
behindert die die ohnehin grund vater
wenn software ist berufsoffizier und
meist nur an den wochenenden zu hause
[Musik]
als bester freund lorenzo ist oft und
gerne bei fans zu besuch
es sind sehr laut sein leben auch
richtig sie fühlt sich nicht
ich mache einfach das was ihnen gefällt
das machen was wir machen wollen und das
finde ich einfach super weil jetzt halt
zu sagen es sind viele finde ich schämen
sich wenn sie ihn was anders machen dann
machen sie es auch nicht das will ich
einfach schade den mut nicht zu haben
sondern man muss einfach nichts hart
haben dass man ihnen was an das macht
das andere das machen alle und ich war
mir der ferien nicht nicht sofort
stellen
[Musik]
als eltern hätten ihm gerne ein gesundes
geschwister zur seite gestellt die
trauer über den zweiten behinderten sohn
dauert ein ganzes jahr bis zum besuch
einer nachbarin diebe grad im opferstock
sie und trolley wie entwickelt wie die
frau zum scholl seite schneller
zerstreut großes berührte lisbeth und
wie schon bruder conti hatte früher
komme das geld mehr einfach so ganz
nebenbei projektiert einig so wick kam
die who akzeptiert und agogisch
behindert und ich hatte schon letzten
minute rooney flotte um es schlechte
gewissen und dort tatsächlich kräht und
hört weg ist nicht alles wird die hitze
und die brauchen und vielleicht auch
später aber das hat wirklich seine
zuflucht
[Musik]
weil der schulzeit an natürlich aber
nicht so viel zu ja manchmal schalte zu
stehen schlecht denn vielleicht gerade
auf 200 doppel sowieso garantiert
personal eingestellt doch nicht aus und
ich sitze dass du dich unter druck
gesetzt fühlt damit die tasten haut also
klar dass ihre familie mit paar theorien
wie ich es eilig das ist das schloss
aber eine grundsätzlich nicht
verpflichtet weil bäume in die nacht
aber eloge natürlich organ das ist aus
familie gurke diese familie an im
seepark wandel ich war und ziehe ich
dass wir alle gemeinsam auf die trümmer
und das gleich noch mal wenn man das
team ist eine mannschaft und deutlich
einfacher leaderposition
und das ist auch so mit und das
christkind in sachen wie zum guten 2
das ist zwar traurig aber und hätte
anders aussieht wie sich ja nicht nur
mehr schwer es ist sehr viel schönes und
sehr lustig und sehr viel
die ganze leistungsgesellschaft
niedrigste und da ganz notendruck und
dass man auch so erreicht
daher ist natürlich das ganz anders und
der schwelmer sehr viel mit unserer das
raten die waage
anja wurde mit 12 zum young care ihre
mutter war an hepatitis c erkrankt zehn
jahre nach der diagnose starb sie
es zeigt den haushalt führen kochen für
die beiden geschwister und den von
berufstätigen vater anja musste schnell
in ihre neue rolle hineinwachsen und sie
leistete noch weit mehr
anja unterstützte die an hepatitis
unheilbar erkrankte mutter auch
emotional in dem sie ein feines gespür
für deren gemütslage entwickelte denn
die mutter war durch die ausweglosigkeit
der situation in eine depression
gefallen und auf die andere sieht
einfach nimmer markant und denkt so der
die zerrissenheit eigentlich dass er hat
das eine ganz persönliche begriff
schwierig sei bedrückend also
als mittleres von drei kindern versuchte
anja auch ihrer kleinen schwester so gut
es ging die mutter zu ersetzen sie über
90 mit dem berufs und ja sie gänzlich
oscar und geist im oktober brachte
unerwartet und über den haag und oed und
minimal mit der kultur stellen damit das
recht mit und ja er in dem moment gar
nicht so genau wie ich möchte ich meine
größte und das ist für mich und ich
brauchte einen moment taste drückt von
mutter carole agieren meist im
verborgenen
manchmal ist es der erkrankten
elternteil manchmal sind es die
pflegenden kinder welche über die
situation stillschweigen bewahren wollen
im dorf der beiden schwestern wurde
trotzdem geredet wenn sie familie damit
überhaupt machbar ist das ist jetzt
alles versucht dass auch die trainer
möglichkeiten
deutschland sarahs vater ist ingenieur
im maschinen anlagenbau und mitinhaber
einer firma immer wieder muss er für
längere zeit ins ausland
das ist aber nur in dem umfang ist für
den ex freundin ist ziehen wir monat zu
überbieten unterwegs gewinnziel wurde
biggs und das im trimet in shanghai x770
ein anderer ob sie dann hat das anders
gesehen dass ich kann mit dem grund so
dass die nach der job in den praxen
wieder besetzt da sie stufe mit robin
und zum wenig größer ist eine große
welle und jetzt mit der firma lytro
mediums zu sehen also ich hatte das
privileg das sind immerhin so viel
prestige sondern so einen balance-akt
mir kann nicht nur vor der heim aus die
ganze es auch keinen unterschied gibt es
weniger eine dementsprechende aufstieg
[Musik]
das werden wir wieder einige stangen
dieses landes oder stimmungen tisch
[Musik]
wir hätten auch mehr an mich und weiß
nie ob sie danach gibt oder nicht und
wie halte ich den drang hat merkt er
songs heraus denn überhaupt schlafen
nun ja das bin ich morgen mir also sie
verwahrten sich
ich glaube wie realisiert ist doch nicht
die luft einfach sie wird sich sicher
bin und habe und wenn er fordert aber
dann ist für sie schon wieder gut und
sie schläft sie haben schon wieder ihre
stunden ordnung weg zugestanden da ist
jeder geschafft aber jetzt ist so dass
blogger die dynamo schlechte gedanken
was ist denn für schlechte gedanken
nicht gut da
[Musik]
ybbs über fabriken oder die wissen was
immer man will schwierigkeit ist sie
wachse 3 wenn man sagt wir haben sie
eigentlich die trias auch sehr sehr oft
ist es notwendigkeit und das ist halt
ein unterschied zur freiwilligkeit und
wenn das ist eine notwendige situation
ist wird das auch gemacht wenn es
notwendig ist und man sich oft nicht das
eigentliche geschäft wo das sie nach dem
sport so dass die playstation
solche situationen bin ich bestimmt noch
nicht schlagen aber ich glaube man muss
das glas steht da nicht so viel draußen
sitzen und quatschen machen sie zur
hölle mache jetzt vorrats muss man so
von 8
[Musik]
oli die playstation vita
da sollst du okay
[Musik]
trolley machte
[Applaus]
doch nach doch nachdem ist sie ganz lang
war lisa j de compostela unterordnen
da bist michael ich ja super gemacht
denn nach dem täter
oder ich es nicht kann hat die ganz
verschließen
klar ist schon dass schaaf und mama und
komplett über hochwichtig grundsätzlich
ja musiker haben hausaufgaben zu machen
mama oder papa zugelegt aber jeder setzt
das gibt es natürlich zwischen sarah
besucht die sechste klasse vor diesen
dreharbeiten wussten ihre schulkameraden
nichts von ihrer rolle als jan käme den
grund für ihre zeitweilige müdigkeit und
die konzentrationsprobleme könnten nur
ihr lehrer erzählt sie weiß aber dass
ich das dorf und sie wahr ist dass wir
sehr sorgfältig behandelt und sie sollen
entscheiden wann sie welche reform vor
den bug druck machen ich glaube daran
hat gelehrt dass man sie die schule ist
dass sie wie alles rund um sich selber
wirklich an russland und sich dann eben
besser auf touren kommt zum trierer dann
wenn sie der hs ist sie wahrscheinlich
sehr konzentriert auf die sache frage
stellte eine positive oder negative
schluss ist
ein großer rückschritt oder als auch wie
hier und jetzt davon gibt es bei vega
also die pedalerie und andere
konzentriere mich nachher sie macht
virtuell ich fenster das erzähle sah es
aus wie ein das schulfest und ethisch
alles gut geht möchte sony geräte über
schwierigkeit und das auf ein trio die
hand und ein handys fenster die fenster
und die zins konfrontiert mit ganz
schwierige situationen wo
mitverantwortung äußere sich zwischen
mit erwachsenen verbindet braucht wird
und dennis russischen teil ist dass sie
wenn sie das erkennt und merkel habe ist
die heirat alles komplett anders wir zum
spiel im kolleg und wieder kollegin und
um ganz oft verstecken oder dann gibt es
eine andere situation wo vom ph es war
schon ein gewisser druck da und im 7
unbewusste pf lustig vor der person noch
frankreich wo eigentlich mit wo das
dürfen nachweislich umgangssprachlich
was gott ab die high und deine familie
skills sie schafft es nicht oder sie
sind anders oder gar noch schlimmer in
die schlichtweg 2 oder mit konsequenzen
über irgendwelche institutionen
reagieren extrem wichtig
[Musik]
der ausbruch der krankheit ihrer mutter
kam fast gleichzeitig mit alias wechsel
in die oberstufe die leistungen der
guten schülerin fakten plötzlich ab
da hätten wir viele zur burg stoffe oder
ungarn im sommer gelesen oder bio delia
würde mit der kollegin gewachsen und hat
auch im youz gleich geschafft aus migros
mit schutzwällen nehmen sich gerade
nicht so dass ich möglichst sexy zieht
ich glaube wir uns sehr auf wiesen
wachsen ist wenn ich zurückdenke
und eigentlich benjamin brafman ganz
ihren lehrern und mitschülern erzählte
anja nichts von der schwierigen
situation zu hause
man muss sich vorstellen sind der gruppe
digitale im fußballclub und eine von ihr
ebenfalls patrick kurth und dann ist da
natürlich die logische folgerung streich
nie
und noch eine herrscht am 4.12 und sage
ich gar nicht hoch
wegen schwerer krankheit kann will ich
die heimat als ich gerade da im alter
extrem schwierig
über mobbing will sarah nicht reden
doch auch sie hat ihre erfahrungen damit
gemacht heute fühlt sie sich wohl in der
klasse und hat einigen freundinnen auch
von ihrer situation erzählt doch keine
kann ihr die sorge darüber abnehmen was
sie nach der schule zu hause an trifft
kollegen macht dass sie da hier die
großmutter ist auch heute da wie immer
wenn silvia ketterer im haushalt
unterstützung braucht damit sarah nicht
zu viel zugemutet wird es machen oder
sich das und den macht sie das nicht so
viel machen aber sie macht gleich oder
das sieht dass die trasse sei oft
klaglos würde eine haushaltshilfe sie
nicht entlasten
ja es war essen entlastet dass das eben
das probiert zum faltrad sind leisten
die hand der arm ist und ich kann alles
extrem gut nicht für selbstverständlich
habe ich glaube es war
was drauf für sie wenn sie nicht treffen
[Musik]
spaß macht und nicht einfach mal so wie
ich und ich haben
[Musik]
schlag
häufig waren sechs zentren schloss sie
und fluggerät und also sich kreiert und
jetzt ist ja schon da und das ist
wunderschön
wieso sie hat einen öffner man merkt
dass sich die sicherheitszone hart und
und was sie ja gern durch
[Musik]
zunächst darf für zwei jahre zum greifen
ja nur
[Musik]
die bedürfnisse von pflegenden kindern
und jugendlichen sind sehr
unterschiedlich ich brauche
und 14
ich brauche aber jetzt natürlich nötig
wurde jetzt vielleicht einfach
instrument und dadurch druck anzeigen
das ist mir die notfall kontaktliste
wenn die bz berichtete weil sie ganz
genau dass ich meine erste priorität und
aber anderswo 18 ins einstellungspflicht
völlig andere unterstützung hat er ist
jetzt um gespielt viel flexibler casini
arbeit ab keine berufsschule anja und
vanessa wussten was sie gebraucht hätten
als es ihrer mutter immer schlechter
ging und diese zeitweise trost im
alkohol suchte eine ansprechperson
sie fragten in einer psychiatrischen
klinik nach und erhielten den lapidaren
rat in der nächsten schwierigen
situation doch einfach die polizei zu
rufen und die mutter einweisen zu lassen
situationen garros kritische worte seien
einfach machtlos gefühlt und denn ich
sehe eigentlich mit dem auto das fahrrad
ist sie sowieso darum krieg und oskar
das hier unfall macht oder dass es
passiert und heute moment dass polizei
und dissidenten abgeführt schloss man
sich nicht ganz im gegenteil
also minimal hat sich glaube und
vertraue ihr genehmen arctic sea und
haut aussieht am ganzen kreis rasen wo
sie gerade das ist ja dass die
finanzierung das psychiatrische der
polizist vielleicht noch analog und
sagen hey auf die geburt ist völlig
[Musik]
anja und ihre schwester schafften den
kraftakt an der seite ihrer kranken
mutter ihre berufslehre abzuschließen
vanessa gehen in die pflege anja lernte
floristin heute sechs jahre nach dem tod
der mutter ist anja ebenfalls in
ausbildung zur pflegefachfrau
schwerpunkt psychiatrie und versucht
viele junge erwachsene die ähnliches
erlebt haben wie anja ergreifen einen
beruf in der pflege hier am
berufsbildungszentrum in olten arbeitet
man deshalb am forschungsprojekt janka
es mit ein gesicht gibt dass man die
thematik thematisiert dass man sie
wahrnehmen
das ziel ist ganz klar sensibilisieren
will
dies erlaube nicht aus wenn ich im
unterricht das thema aufgriff und sex
affären mit der park kurze beispiel dazu
denn zehn ich schaue wie swh macht
wieder studierende hat das entdecken
dass in ihrem kurs oder habe sagte janka
roxy oder dass ich mir gar nicht bewusst
dass das überhaupt geht gewaltig und
beispiel war die studierenden noch bei
diesem risiko und die zeigen wie groß
das thema eingerichtet
und ich glaube nicht mehr sensibilisiert
ich finde ich sagen wenn ich jetzt so
praxis kommen und wenn ich jetzt wieder
der familie am krankenbett oder in der
psychiatrie oder in spitex unsere
studierenden denn sagen sie ganz kleines
kind ist ein wirklich ganz
das kind aussprache und ich glaube 1000
studierende über schweiz verteilt und
praktikums in der verschiedenste
bereiche wenn das erreichen dass die
dort geflogen
das hauptziel erreicht 59 und 9 sind
[Musik]
hätte ich gedacht dass das ich hoffe
augen zum teil das land negativ wird
dass janko ich habe das negative der
spieler stimmt schlaflosigkeit oder
sorge also jugendliche übernahmen
gewachsen sind selbständige zum teil
glaube ich hat das beziehe in deine
familie viel intensiver sind und ich das
gefühl habe belaste gleichzeitig sehr
intensiv figur die bezirke innerhalb der
familie weiter stärken und fernsehen als
ich glaube rang erasmus überhaupt nicht
negativ sondern es gibt sehr viel ganz
gut die positiv erlebt im vorjahr rang
heraus
[Musik]
qs eltern bemühen sich ihren mittleren
sohn immer wieder besondere
aufmerksamkeit zu schenken
heute unternimmt er mit vater wasser
einen ausflug auf dem militärflugplatz
emmen den jewels leidenschaft geht ja
luftfahrt und - venedig aus entweder
komplett oder heli pilot macher im
berichtsmonat andere der woche die
sozialkompetenz peter wenig dass das
klappt natürlich sehr wertvoll wie sie
machen sich praktisch nie wieder macht
er vieles kommen im set als auch wie ich
sehr diszipliniert welche eher größer
haft
ausdrücklich vorbildliche sohn war nie
wirklich stolz als pilot hemmstoff
verantwortlich für dieses flugzeug fürs
volk führe
heimatland für sicherheit vom luftraum
verantwortlich und dass endlich die
brüder erklärt ja sicher ziel der
forschung ist die chancengleichheit für
young care es in schule und spätere
ausbildung
das ist nicht so dass sie nicht der
reiche aber sie könnte man mal nicht das
erreichen was ich gerne würde das heißt
zimmer hat wo besser passt
beispielsweise dass die studie ort genau
das was die haie ist dass man nur den
widrigkeiten obwohl man sie schlecht für
ganz anders studium medien interessieren
oder arbeitgeber sucht wieder soweit die
show wohl vielleicht bis anders
besseberg
ihrem carrolls gab es schon immer und
wird es immer geben
sarah und schuhe geben ihnen ein gesicht
sie werben um verständnis und
wertschätzung für kinder und jugendliche
in ähnlichen situationen politik und
gesellschaft sind eingeladen ihnen
unterstützend zur seite zu stehen
ich bin stolz wie sie das ganze manager
tor dieser situation umgeht wie sich
damit auseinandersetzen und auch
probiert special teams machen dass ich
es nicht kann dass ich viel erlebt hat
und dass ich mich wie handels lava und
die traurigen moment das danken was
passiert mit denen nicht vergessen aber
wie im hintergrund gestellt
[Musik]